なんだ twitter とかビジネスさんが言ってたんですけど
馬鹿だなあ送った後にスプライトを飲むと必ず吐くみたいなそういうコーデな流れて
いるわけですよ
源さんどんな降った後にしづらいと思ってくださいねこうやっぱ
いろんな形を言ってくるわけなんでねアーマーまぁ ok そんなネバーなった
あとにすぐライト運ゲゲロ吐くわけないじゃないですかそれではなかったらよくないと
思って僕がねこう
今日はねまあんだとディスプレイとが取って度かじゃないのその
賢者になるとやっぱそういうものは結構
催すということは非常に少なくなる隔離全員買うと率からしてもかなり高一般と下回る
確認
頭を叩きだすと思うのでお前らあんまり電話情報に騙されるな
用意するものはこちらですまだとスプライトですだこういうネット世代だからな
ステマ増補に流せる安いんだなああそういえばネットに並べたこと部のみ実戦並みなん
で実際行くお試してみて
真実と見世物おこう確かで打つから金やっぱり今の社会が必要ということで町西
にあるのが一番早いというわけですよ
me
me ん
2ん
ん
1 a
ませんよほら大丈夫だ俺は女にそこらへん奴は違うからな
そういうそういうこういうのじゃ僕が書かないですよ
全然
これ本当に把握の大丈夫なんですけど
これどれだけ飲めばいいの全部のた方がいいですか
いやえっこれ履かないよ
これ本当に
[音楽]
ほら儚いすすめ
ん
[拍手]
これウソでしょ
はなよん
まず幅ないからん
ねっはちょっとこれどうあ的にどうなの動画的には家童話的に何も面白くないん
でどうやった履くの
履きたい花井と動画的に
あ
ビッ
ちょっと
まず
これ動画的にどうなの入った方がいいの
生えた方がいいなぁえっ
ぷっ
ああああああ
いいし
ています